what I'm saying is you put your adult
priorities for it you wanted to chase a
dream but you also wanted to provide a
living for your family right so I missed
you a lot on big events but when you
were in town you were there and you made
up for it and you were there as much as
I needed you to be or wanted to be and
you never pushed that boundary over the
line right so what I'm saying is like if
you have work or you have other things
that you're doing or chasing that's fine
but make sure that your kid doesn't ever
feel unnoticed that's what I meant like
like you want to always make sure you're
there for them um but I also wouldn't
say can I can
I jump in sure so what you're saying is
nobody expects you to be there all of
the time but when you're there be there
yeah 100% yeah that makes sense and also
I mean I I've said I say this every time
obviously you I know you want to be a
friend to your kid because my dad and I
are best friends however there needs to
be a line between parent and friend